um she's a friend she's amazing
she's your comedian comedian yeah this
is vicky gumbel's yeah no no no it's um
what's her name oh it may just looks
like her oh no she's not comedian
okay she's she's chin's axe and he
screwed her over not my ex
we set you in up uh with chender a while
back on a date with this beautiful young
lady
so but she's uh you know just like the
rest of us during quarantine and just in
life
you know love can be kind of uh you know
something we all
yeah capricious uh nick you want to
bring her in here chan you want to bring
her in actually chen
very pretty girl yeah this is uh my my
first ever
chinder date carly graduations
[Applause]
what's up carly you know not much
okay well look carly uh you guys want to
take us
uh everybody needs a little bit of uh
luck and love and
and can also use some suggestions and
guidance sometime that's
a little direction a little direction so
that's why we have here uh dr drew and
mike um
i just want to know what's going on with
your love life and if you have any
questions you could use some answers for
some suggestion uh
um love life is
pretty much the same dating nothing like
crazy serious
and i don't know that's kind of like
about about it
how old are you you don't mind me asking
i'm just turning 20
just turned 26 two weeks ago all right
you're right in the thick of it this is
my personal opinion i'm a guy
i can't put myself in your shoes but
this is from what i've seen and i'm only
talking through my experience wait till
you're about
32 to start realistically thinking about
finding
a lifelong part smart because
not to their own fault men in their
20s mid 20s animals until the advanced
guy can be like 26 27 like drew sons
they're
they're pretty square away guy like me i
was like 32 33 before i even had the
ability
to invest real um sympathy and interest
into
a female what if she dated older guys
they should get guys in their early 30s
yeah yeah you're at that age where i
think it's not gross the point is
men or animals until they're about 27.
they should we should be like we should
have been caged
we're super super here should have been
just caged and put in a cage
we are he literally was put in the cage
all of a sudden he was caged
yeah all if we're all going to be in a
half of our friends are in cages we're
going to be in a zoo soon
okay you're just really insecure right
you don't have a lot going on for
yourself most of the time
most guys most guys are 25 26 they're
just they're trying to put their life
together they're working they're
typically really invested in their
career building themselves and then they
don't even get that
kind of free um that that that that that
processing power to think about like oh
my god this is a human being and i gotta
really listen to her when she has
problems and i gotta invest my time into
what's going on in her life and it's
there and they're also
pumping testosterone through their body
so they're [ __ ] horny monkeys
it's a really bad combo yeah and
and but the other thing is that men for
whatever reason males seem to
need a sense of their identity in the
world before they can understand who
they are and then be available for
another person yeah right yeah
but but she can have fun you're saying
before she gets serious no do your thing
do your thing
right yeah you're you're a living
breathing human being that has needs
and desires go have fun do your thing
i'm saying don't get serious
don't or or find yourself a guy who's 33
and really to treat you like you're a
princess so that was our 12-minute
diatribe of her telling us how old she
is
she didn't ask us any questions or sting
it
uh real housewives of orange county
jesus christ now
uh when it comes to these relationships
or this dating do you try to make
yourself a little more available and do
you find that a lot of guys are
like based on what mike and drew were
saying are you finding that to be kind
of true
or what do you think
i think it can go both ways i mean
there's so
i'm 26 i usually tend to date older
because growing up
you're always told like men have what
are like two years younger in maturity
level
yeah more likely maybe more yeah maybe
ten
but i think yeah i mean
my track record is a lot of jerks
so and then i think like the few ones
that were nice it was just like timing
didn't work out well
oh so do you have a broken picker
we gotta kiss some frogs well that's
true but maybe
maybe her picker's off she's sort of
attracted to the a-holes yeah you got
this drew
yeah i think my finger's definitely all
do you
like the bad boys
yeah kind of but i also think that
i was listening to something and it was
about like you know i think it
may be the same with men too but just
that the challenge or like the chase or
the
yeah like the bad boy douchey kinds like
i don't know why but somehow their
women find them more interesting or
maybe not always it's usually
primal it's it's younger women and most
women
outgrow that by around 22 23 so you need
to outgrow this is not
you are not going to change them it is
not going to go well
yeah i can definitely say i'm i'm pretty
over that i will say like
uh there was a period of time like i
think all that just gains
a lot of it comes with like maturity and
dating right
looking back like obviously at college
that's not dating
um and then even after college just
still not really being mature in dating
and then now it's been a couple years
and i'm 26 and
um i think just even looking at the last
two years like
you kind of have to like grow within
yourself and like i know for me like
and so how did the tinder date figure
into this well
well chin chin and her shared a bunch of
sake
and then
it was so funny because they tried to do
this segment called chinder and i was
single at the time
and then right when we found carl that
right around that time is when i started
dating my
my best friend and chin didn't tell us
this or i couldn't i don't want to ruin
it for everyone so i was like ah it's
already too late we already did this
committed committed to the
to the product i get that yeah she was
awesome now carly i have a question now
these men that you're
spending time with are these when it
comes to sexualness are you guys ha
are they are these men you know real
confident or they erect or what's going
on there
what do you mean like are just are they
are they having like erectile problems
are you noticing anything like that with
some of these younger fellows are they
too aggressive maybe a little bit
that's your buddy
how's chin's bulgogi that's what we're
asking
no i just want to know if you're seeing
any sexual difficulties with these damn
young the youngins
with these youngsters yeah
no can't can't say no well
okay wow i like anything i'm saying
that i feel like especially with guys
like in my
age range and like i have friends i have
guy friends that are my best friends
so i know whatever they're doing well
those guys are stalking you just so you
know
i'm not kidding best friends that are
your men friends they're waiting for
their moment
i've always said that not that you can't
not that you can't be friends with men
i'm not saying that
i'm saying well okay i think it's i
think he overstated by saying they're
stalking you here's
the true true reality here's the reality
you're very you're very attractive girl
you seeming you're
seemingly very nice you have a good
energy about you they may not be
actively stalking you but at any given
point
even though they're your friends they
want to at any given point if you're
like
we should just [ __ ] they'd be like yeah
yeah you're right you're totally right
and i'm gonna do this right guys these
guys used to call us on love line
all the time her friends well
the equivalent of this we heard this all
the time
and they would go like you know did you
let let me ask you this did you at
one time your best friends did you at
one time have a date with in
at the beginning of the relationship or
a couple of dates
no so you never dated these guys ever
okay well that's good like a lot of my
best guy friends like or
ones that are single i should say yeah
um they are just strictly friends
has there been the encounter that you're
talking about where your friend yeah
didn't want to date me yes but we're not
friends right
drew and mike on this at any given point
those boys want in the game well there's
opportunities
the ones you got to watch were the ones
that that you dated and then he settles
for friend
that guy's talking oh that guy's talking
classic stuff and are y'all doing drugs
too
what's that that that doesn't really
work because
yeah he's a doctor though you know and
then you want to be friends you're gonna
hook up again like that's a dead
giveaway
but then are you friends though
you know what i'm saying i don't [ __ ]
yeah you know i've never [ __ ] down
that i'm being friends well i'm friends
with somebody i'm not [ __ ] yeah my
best friend let me [ __ ] other people you
feel me
mike there was that one time yes we
weren't supposed to talk about that on
the air
but i wrecked his [ __ ] but i'm glad
to know that you are still enjoying
some good times during the disease you
know yeah that is good yeah
it's important to know that people are
out there in case the world ends that
people are still doing sex and people
are still doing stuff
yeah i agree you know what i really
appreciate chin keeping it real like a
korean man
pour my drink you pour my drink dude
mike knows the culture
that's right i i was blown away i had
two korean girlfriends and i
that always blew my [ __ ] mind because
the women have to pour the drink poor
poor might the soju i would
be barely finished boom poor drink open
the door for me and it's like and it's
not
not anymore brother have you gone on if
you go on a date with the korean in 2020
it's the woke culture
is that true has it been ruined i
haven't haven't dated a korean girl for
a long time